christmas is a time of comfort joy and
cocoa by the tree but if you're in the
right kind of mood it's also a time for
killer Santa's demonic elves and other
seasonal frights if you want to curl up
by the fire for a monstrous movie
marathon here are the best and worst
films out there for your Yuletide sleigh
black Christmas is the twisted godmother
of holiday horror films the plot is a
familiar one with a mysterious killer
picking off victims in a sorority house
around Christmas but more than four
decades after its release this wintery
slasher still wins over viewers with
this haunting holiday tone the film
features terrifying murder sequences
compelling performances and one of the
most unsettling phone calls and horror
movie history all set against a cozy
Christmas backdrop
nearly a decade later director Bob Clark
did a complete turnaround with a very
different holiday classic the slightly
less violent a Christmas story now
that's a double feature it's no surprise
that black Christmas got the extreme
remake treatments but louder gorya and
darker doesn't necessarily equal better
released in 2006 this second incarnation
attempted to flesh out exactly what was
behind the brutal murders at the
sorority house and while the answer to
that mystery is satisfyingly bizarre it
does pull time away from the victims and
their stories aside from spelling out
the killer's origins the remake attempts
to distinguish itself through
increasingly disgusting murder sequences
but it's all just soulless violence with
little charm or fun to be found for all
its effort to grow its mythology and
serve up twisted kill scenes the end
result is both too much and not enough
there are plenty of Christmas movies
that explore the mythology of Santa
Claus each one hoping to add something
to the legend few films really succeed
at this one exception is rare exports a
finished film that offers a fascinating
creepy new take on father Christmas
perhaps the best thing about the film is
the way it plays with the tropes of
Christmas movies there's a struggling
family a boy searching for a reason to
believe in magic and some wonderful
supernatural happenings all twisted into
a frightening fantasy tale it's a film
that both celebrates and subverts
Christmas shattering the illusions as
characters have about the holiday as the
dark truth about Santa Claus is
unearthed for at least one Christmas Eve
you'll be thinking about Saint Nick very
differently you probably don't want to
let that guy in your house Silent Night
deadly night as a campy slash a classic
with one of the best posters in horror
history but its sequel is mostly a dull
retread of the first film and is about
as much fun as a lump of coal thanks to
a flimsy framing device the movie spends
a huge chunk of its run time on
flashbacks as a results a whole lots of
footage from the first movie is reused
by the time the film gets around a new
material you're bored enough to turn it
off you may as well stick with the
original or press pause on the horror
movie
go spend time with your family why would
I want to do that if you're looking for
the creepiest film about a killer Santa
then seek out Christmas Eve oh it's the
story of a man whose perception of Saint
Nick was forever warped by a childhood
incident leaving him feeling responsible
for keeping the spirit of Christmas
alive himself that warped vision
ultimately makes him one to be Santa
keeping tabs on local children which
despite Santa's example is an insanely
scary thing to do it all leads up to a
murder spree that plays out in a way
that's much less campy than you might
expect forget the reason for the season
this is just a bonafide horror film with
a desire to truly scare that make sin
under scene Jam your name goes in a bed
boys and girls book and I'll bring you
something horrible Jack Frost has not by
traditional standards a good movie it's
the story of a serial killer whose DNA
merges with snow after the truck taking
him to be executed crashes into some
toxic goo
he then takes a form of a sentient
shape-shifting snowman who terrorizes a
small town with his crappy visual
effects despite failing with both
critics and audiences Jack Frost has
stuck around since it's 1997 release
seemingly blissfully unaware of just how
bad it is do you want to holiday movie
with a bit of spooky flair that won't
scar the kids for life then watch
gremlins Joe Dante's classic about a boy
in a strange paired Christmas present
has been a source of imaginative fun for
30 years every 80s kid knows who can't
feed a Mogwai after midnight even if
gremlins to admits that role doesn't
really make sense what if they're eating
in an airplane and they cross a time
zone I mean it's always midnight
somewhere
Santa's sleigh might be a bad movie but
it's hard to watch without having a good
time
famously starring professional wrestler
Bill Goldberg the film goes all-in on
its premise of a murderous Santa and
this is no mere imitator this is a
real-deal Kris Kringle coming straight
out of the depths of hell
Santa's sleigh is pulled by demonic
reindeer and he keeps things brutally on
brand taking out all of his victims in a
seasonally appropriate way this
villainous st. Nicholas isn't just a
Santa gone mad he's a Santa born bad
it's so stupid that it's awesome but
it's still really really stupid
the Internet's favorite Christmas
Monster has a movie well worth watching
Krampus arts is a story of a
dysfunctional family coming together for
a tense holiday reunion with one side
being uptight and the other being a
little gun crazy when one of the kids
loses a Christmas spirit and shreds his
letter to Santa things quickly take a
chilling turn a blizzard sets in and the
power goes out leaving the family
waiting for a visit not from Santa but
rather his dark shadow well-made and
delightfully feisty Krampus as a
creature feature for all seasons a work
of horror comedy that just works on
every level enough murderous Santa's how
about a killer elf most of this horror
unfolds at a department store where a
group of teenagers and an ex-cop Santa
impersonator are spending the night it
turns out they aren't alone because a
strange elf creature is also roaming
around raising hell they have magical
powers that can't be hurt or killed they
eat anything they're a perfect soldier
that sounds like an okay premise but
elves get so much stranger the Dan
Haggerty starring movie is so bad with a
story so bonkers but it's actually kind
of good what do Santa's little helpers
have in common with a secret nasty plot
it's way more than you'd expect you'll
have to see it to believe it but you
just might wish you hadn't
[Music]